Cass can get disrupted for a variety of
reasons sometimes schedules change
sometimes personal problems can lead an
actor to drop out in some cases things
still turn out well or even better for
the films in question but in others it
damages the cast chemistry and dooms the
film one of the most famous recasting of
all time was that of Eric Stoltz and
Back to the Future Stoltz was the
original Marty McFly a time-traveling
teenager who's accidentally sent back to
the year 1955 he was replaced with
Michael J Fox a little over a month into
shooting Lea Thompson who played Marty's
mom Lorraine told The Hollywood Reporter
in 2015 that the switch was very
difficult for her as she was very good
friends with Stoltz fellow cast mate
Christopher Lloyd who starred as
inventor Doc Brown gave a radio
interview in 2012 and described the
moment the cast found out Stoltz was
history it was during an intense period
of night shooting after he'd been
working with Stoltz every night for
three weeks
he noted that Stoltz was a very good
actor but producers needed someone with
more of a comic flair in the role Boyd
was terrified when he reshot his scenes
with Fox but he was happy that it all
worked out in the end
Great Scott did it ever this young adult
romance between high school student
Bella Swan and vampire Edward Cullen
captivated readers and moviegoers around
the globe in the first two Twilight
films the vampire Victoria was played by
Rachelle Lefevre
but in the third entry Eclipse Victoria
didn't seem like her old self as Lefevre
placed by Bryce Dallas Howard Summit
Entertainment and LaFave and an
awkwardly public battle over the moon
with the actress saying she was stunned
and the studio countering that they were
disappointed by her attempt to make her
career choices the fault of the studio
whether the fault lay with Lefevre
summit's ruthlessness the switch was
hard on her cast mates Jackson Rathbone
who played cullen coven member Jasper
Hale noted that lefebvre's a dear friend
whom he was going to miss terribly and
Peter Facinelli who starred as Edward's
adoptive father declared that he loved
her like a sister
angley picked up a Best Director Oscar
for Life of Pi his adaptation of Yann
Martel's novel in which a man retells
the story of his weak surviving in a
shipwreck at the age of 16 adrift on the
Pacific Ocean with only a Bengal tiger
and his lifeboat for company his story
is told to a writer who is
playing in the film by Rafe spall but
originally that part was filled by Tobey
Maguire Lee ended up removing Maguire
after shooting Rams because he felt his
presence took away from the story he
insisted that he loved Tobey whom he had
worked with previously in 1997 sea ice
storm but he worried that it would be
distracting to have a big movie star
sitting there for such a small part
earth on Khan who played the adult pie
was jarred by the recasting as it meant
he had to reshoot those scenes he was
worried about having to make a big
emotional investment all over again but
it ended up working out as he learned
from his director to use the opportunity
constructively there was a lot of
pressure to deliver satisfying sequels
to The Matrix the groundbreaking 1999
sci-fi cyberpunk classic that pressure
only increased when numerous production
issues led observers to wonder if the
series was cursed
this included numerous deaths of cast
members including Gloria foster who
played the Oracle and who passed away
just after the filming of the Matrix
Reloaded and there was also the tragic
case of Aaliyah
who was initially cast as E and reloaded
the singer and actress was killed in a
plane crash at the age of 22 in the
midst of production co-star Harold
Perrineau remembered her fondly it was
really heartless personally it was a
really hot loss fit a community of music
and entertainment in and we miss him the
Rio dissing process for Z took many
months eventually no nag a daughter of
singer Marvin Gaye was cast as her
replacement the drama on the set of 1996
is the island of dr. Moreau is legendary
it may have started when Bruce Willis
had to drop out of the lead role and
director Richard Stanley was reportedly
told the only way to save the film was
to hire Val Kilmer who ultimately
realized his leverage and allegedly
started making demands Stan Lee was
eventually replaced by John
Frankenheimer but that didn't stop
Kilmer from causing disruptions
according to crew members he would
arrive late change dialogue and bully
the cast and crew one witness reported
that he even intentionally burned a
cameraman right on his face with a
cigarette Kilmer's behavior also led him
to a feud with co-star Marlon Brando
Kilmer repeatedly refused to emerge from
his trailer until Brando was on set and
Brando would only come on to the set
after a private discussion with
Frankenheimer according to the director
this led to
days going by without any footage being
shot as extra sat around on their makeup
and full costumes in the heat when
Charlie Hunnam and Dakota Johnson were
announced as the stars of Fifty Shades
of Grey it looked like they had the
chemistry necessary for the bondage
laced tale yet that chemistry wasn't
enough to keep Hunnam on board for weeks
before shooting was set to commence he
dropped out citing scheduling conflicts
Johnson later explained during an
interview with David Letterman that it
was a confusing moment for her poems
replacement Jamie Dornan seemed to
mollify some fan objection but by all
accounts like the chemistry Johnson had
with hanaman for one thing their press
tour was low-energy their that instant
chemistry know you hate each other he's
hard to work with and while the film was
a hit the paradin generated enough
sparks to win over most critics
[Music]